but we certainly know the date now the  6th of May and next year lots of  speculation about when it would be  Saturday the 6th of May we know this  date chosen in conjunction not just with  the palace but the Church of England the  government as well to ensure there were  no clashes that it was the most  practical and pragmatic date we  understand the service itself will take  place at Westminster Abbey as  coronations have done for 900 years and  will be conducted by the Archbishop of  Canterbury Justin Welby it'll see the  king crowned and also his wife Camilla  the queen consort we do know that at 74  which is the age or B become next mayor  he will be the oldest person to be  crowned in British history as to what  the service and ceremony will look like  I think it will be more modest and  certainly shorter perhaps than previous  coronations perhaps even an hour some  suggestions although there's been no  confirmation yet of the length of the  service